[Music]
I'm mindful tonight this afternoon as I
begin of
the caricature of Jesus who had some
hard things to say at times and we're
told that he had tears in his
voice I ask that you would pray for me
tonight that I would have tears in my
voice as I
speak and as I attempt to pull back the
curtain a little bit on the state of my
Heritage coming soon to a church near
you emergent
adventism in very early 1970s Elder
Walter Wright warned a school teacher
who was moving to Ohio to be
careful why
the reason he gave it was a very liberal
conference that was 1970 that was 40
years ago he was of course
correct fast forward to
1998 the previous conference president
Elder Raj adakin becomes president of
the Ohio
conference within two years
a powerful
effective regime was assembled in Ohio
Progressive individuals were summoned
from around the country to be a part of
this regime and we began to hear a lot
of new names around Ohio many of them
started with
s Seline scriven cold and
others the Pastors in Ohio what what
about them well they were gradually
calibrated into this spiritual
experiment and what were the guiding
elements of this experiment
number
one any idea was a good
idea now this is a Hallmark of classic
liberalism it starts out magnanimous and
often generous
apparently and you get the idea from the
memo that went around throughout the
conference this appeal for ideas that
eventually found its way onto the
Spectrum
website um some of the ideas were pretty
outlandish
I don't think there were any protest
marches for homosexual land
turtles but there was one idea that was
suggested online that actually happened
and this was from the
educational secretary there in
Ohio he said I have an idea let's build
a
school for kids with no
Adventist influence whatsoever in this
way we will be building the
kingdom and instead of the 7eventh day
Adventist conference president saying
come here partner come here that's a
really bad
idea go do something
useful instead the idea was
applauded it was
louded by adakin SEL Leen Kaiser
hitchock and Hitchcock and others hey
that's a great idea no it wasn't we
should have heard the sound of righteous
rebuke from that idea but instead we
heard a different sound namely the sound
of a wall
falling our mission to the world is not
essential at least that's what I heard
in that statement our task of calling
the remnant out of Babylon was
unnecessary friends if the foundation of
the in a church crumbles if a house
crumbles how will our movement
stand the worst of all despotism is the
heartless tyranny of ideas number
two it was a progressive Faith with a
dynamic understanding of the word of God
one that apparently came right out of
the center for Creative Ministries in
the North American division now what's
wrong with that a progressive Faith with
a dynamic understanding of the word of
God
sounds okay
right well let me unpack that just a
little bit for you I work in an industry
I own a business where high pressure is
often used and there's a difference
between static and dynamic pressure
we're very used to that over 31 years uh
progressivism you're not against
progress are you no no we we need
progress most definitely but what kind
of progress do we need and a dynamic
understanding of the word of God conveys
the
idea that the word of God is movable it
is changeable when you come back
tomorrow it will be different from what
it was yesterday that's what dynamic
means Dynamic pressure is pressure that
changes all the time it might go from
1300 to 3700 PSI Dynamic
understanding not good number
three Doctrine was downplayed as
divisive the only repentance allowed
was repentance from being a legalist
whatever that
is obedience was option but not
essential and I'm not trying to be cute
or funny when I say these things I lived
through them at times they were a cause
of
pain but I can speak about it now with a
clear conscience and an open
heart as this regime gained tremendous
power and I want you to pay attention
here coming soon to a church near
you unless repentance and Revival turns
our churches around as it gained
tremendous power two things happened
number one it became abusive and
controlling pastors who didn't go along
with this seismic shift were pruned away
they hit the road several of them moved
to the safe haven of Michigan amen
amen indeed they weren't welcome in Ohio
the rest were living somewhat high on
the hog teaching these new emphases to
their congregations and number two the
second thing that happened and this is a
bit of a tongue twister was inevitable
integral spirituality I'll say it again
inevitable integral
spirituality 2005 previous conference
president the individual that I've
mentioned already organized a national
Innovation conference now this was a way
to bring emergent thought leaders and
interspiritual mysticism into Ohio and
have our pastors and leaders learn from
these teachers they would then go back
to their congregations teaching them
what they'd learned spreading the virus
Statewide a partial list of innovation
speakers and I'll run through it quickly
includes Leen Kaiser my opinion an
Adventist clairvoyant Leonard site the
chief of angelist for Spiritual
formation Doug padet an emerging Church
thought later his name has come up
number of times Mara Prager Who
self-identifies as a Jewish rabbi Rabbi
ET and teaches people how to connect
with the divine feminine through tarot
cards and I'm not making this
up I could show you the
evidence and lastly the theologically
volatile Sam
salanovic why do I say that in October
of
2010 Samir salanovic held worship
services with wicens at the faith house
Manhattan in New York to celebrate the
occult Festival of Sam Hayne with
them okay in spite of knowing these
things our previous conference president
continued to invite s manovic back to
Ohio a number of years in a row thus
Ohio became an incubator for every wind
of
Doctrine we have a new conference
president now I'm happy to
say the previous president that I have
described retired last year from Ohio
leaving behind sadly a two-fold
legacy acute spiritual confusion and
financial disaster now things were
things were in tough shape there we were
trying to turn the situation around but
this begs the
question could there be a line of
connection between spiritual declension
and the absence of God's material
blessings I'll leave that with
you we're looking back Lessons Learned
what what did we learn from this this
painful
experiment well first the Adventist
mission to prepare the world of Christ
soon return and to call the remnant out
of Babylon became irrelevant
it
happened not to everyone and here I need
to speak a word in favor of the many
faithful Adventists in Ohio who still
love Jesus and who walk forward with
hearts courageous who believe and hang
on to the Adventist message God bless
them and may He multiply them in a state
of
turmoil our Church's doctrines
throughout this experiment were not
essential then into the resulting vacuum
came A Renewed fascination with a
do-it-yourself
spirituality that's what led to this
Innovation conference and I know
firsthand that many conference
presidents around the nation received
invites to come to this conference where
they could be infected with this this um
interp spiritual
bacteria and if I sound like I'm being
hard on it that's intentional I hope I'm
doing it in the right
Spirit well what was driving this what
what was behind this experiment in Ohio
I'm open to your suggestions dear
ones if you have better ideas than mine
feel free to share them but here mine I
believe that he was looking for an edge
in an increasingly hostile and Confused
world I understand that our world is
increasingly
hostile but he was looking in the wrong
places and number two comes from a
French word an we which describes
lethargy which describes when life
becomes uh meaningless it lacks purpose
becomes flaccid
languid all of these colorful adjectives
to describe
boredom and it leaves you wondering
where is God that's a painful place to
be and if you ask questions when you're
in that kind of a spiritual slump and
you come up with the wrong answers your
life will go down into a
spiral fortunately God speaks primarily
through his word doesn't
he yeah and when we grow cold towards it
we are bothered by what we perceive as
God's silence you see that's what drives
many people who are into modern
mysticism they think they have found him
in a soiled urum and Thum hauled from a
Roman
dumpster now I owe so much to the
liberating doctrines of this
church I came out of an Amish menite
community I would have been the eighth
generation I would have had the number
eight on me in fact I had it already and
through a series of events I was exposed
to the Adventist message in truth and I
it shook me to the core I said this
can't be true if it is where has it been
for seven generations and for the next
two years I studied the Adventist
message with one goal in mind that was
to disprove it I
failed I
failed praise the Lord praise the Lord
and sometimes when people come up to me
and they're critical of the Adventist
Church and the Adventist message I say
don't waste your time on that with me I
tried harder than you did for two
years for that reason it is beyond my my
poultry comprehension to understand
those who like Esau before them despise
their ad Birthright how did they do that
I don't despise my Birthright I I don't
despise where I came from I look back on
my Heritage anti Baptist Heritage and I
appreciate many of the things there that
that come out of the Bible and are
rooted in there and I dare say there are
few things we could learn from them and
there's a lot of things they could learn
from us but I don't despise that
Heritage L I am at a loss to understand
how some people who were raised in the
church can come to the point where like
Rick suggested this morning bitterness
begins
to turn their head there is a cure for
bitterness by the way talk to my wife or
I later we we'll tell you what little we
know about that we have a counseling
Ministry we operate out of our
home but in my judgment in my judgment
friends it would be better for these
people to leave the church be more
honorable to either reconcile their
heart to what the church believes and
teaches or leave it
but liberalism is not self- sustaining
it must attach itself to a host to
survive thus resenting the doctrines of
this church and lacking the courage to
leave they set their hand to dismantling
the truths of this movement and order to
satisfy their Progressive
scorn I'm not mad at them I I feel sorry
for them
really we live in a time of many moral
changes friends and there are a lot of
restless people in our world our our
world is under a lot of pressure tonight
A lot of people are hurting tonight and
there are solutions and there are
answers and in a in a room like this
there are people that God wants to use
to bless and touch other people a lot of
them you haven't even met
yet I'm getting ahead of myself I'll
talk about that as I
close but as we live in this world of
these many moral changes and all this
Restless change even in the church
a lot of people are lacking peace within
they want to be part of something bigger
than themselves thus they can escape the
self they hate and by changing
everything around them in the
process they hope to change their own
lives in the
process but it doesn't work pray for
these
people coming soon to a church near
you unless Revival and repentance Chang
changes our
hearts my deep concern with this
Progressive spirituality is that there
is no place for repentance in this
offbeat
movement no place for it and if you
can't repent you're in a heap of
trouble it's like having a broken horn
driving to the repair shop and the sign
on the locked door says honk for
service in the emergent movement it is
cool to seek God but it is not cool to
find
him now speaking of cool the most
coveted demographic for these spiritual
progressives in our our church are the
millennial
generation you know about them right
these are individuals born between 1980
and 2000 both of our sons are
millennials thereafter your children and
mine that's not cool that brings me to
part
two what is happening to to the Youth of
Western culture dear
ones we all know from the various
studies I shouldn't say we all know some
of us probably have followed these
Trends but various studies indicate that
there is a millennial Exodus from the
church and there is also a radical wing
of Christianity this is Christianity at
large all
believers there is a radical wing of
Christianity that says church membership
is no longer necessary thus a rising
generation of 18 to 34 yearold young
people have received a pagan meta
narrative and they are the first
generation to have done so in the last
years I quote Jeremy
riffkin we no longer feel ourselves to
be guest in someone else's home and
therefore obliged to make our Behavior
conform with a set of
preexisting Cosmic rules
that's what we call
worldview it is our creation Now we make
the rules we establish the parameters of
reality we create the world and because
we do we no longer feel beholden to
outside forces we no longer have to
justify our behavior for we are now The
Architects of the
universe we are the kingdom the power
and the glory
forever come God help them spoken by a
millennial about Millennials there are
two powerful forces dear ones driving
spirituality today two powerful forces
driving spirituality today they are
Interfaith mysticism and social justice
ideology I will speak just briefly about
each one of
those in the setting of Millennials you
see Millennials have been infected and
I'm going to introduce a new word here
with monist monist
thinking and I'll come back and explain
what that means try to defend it most
Millennials are unaware of a massive
flip in our
culture you can mention the name Monica
Lewinsky to many Millennials and they
say
who that's a reality check for Our
Generation isn't
it and we are in the midst of change
that's turning the world on its heads
now friends I'm not just an old guy
defending his
generation we are poised tonight between
two worldviews two ways of understanding
the world biblical dualism or Pagan
monism now I told you I would explain
what
the monism means and I'll throw in a
brief explanation of dualism but monism
or oneism as some have referred to it at
is is the belief that there is no
distinction between God and
humans okay that sounds pretty bad no
distinction between creation and Creator
no distinction between male and female
you see this joining of the Opposites
Finds Its most efficient expression in
the efficient homosexual agenda standing
on the shoulders of its grandmother from
cica Falls
feminism this is the embodiment of
Romans 1:1
16-28 where the rightness of God
revealed in the right
by faith is contrasted with those who
exchange the truth of God for a lie it's
the worst trade in the world I've
counseled many many young men who have
struggled with pornography and I and if
they're married I say you've just made
the worst trade in the world you've
exchanged a piece of paper for a real
live woman a wife whom God has given
you and here's a trade that's just as
bad if not worse they exchang the truth
of God for a lie
and worshiped and served created things
rather than the Creator for
them distinctions between Creator and
creation male and female must be
eliminated this is where this Pagan
spirituality is
headed do you want to go
there would you like to see our church
go
there we are in the midst of this kind
of a Revival a pagan Revival you see
secularism is being enfolded into new
spirituality and it's a spirituality
without
religion the emerging church is hand in
glove with this transformation it is the
occulting of the church
friends we can't stop this ideological
leviathon but we can understand it we
can pray for those who are struggling
with
it you see this thing has support in
North America adventism from the very
top down to the bottom blessed is the
man who does not condemn himself by what
he
approves Romans
1422 picture 7 to 800 youth in San Diego
at a one project meeting swaying to the
beat of the drum and the electrifying
music of the
guitar in five years many of
them may possibly be at a Burning Man
festival or lightning in a bottle or
tomorrow land festival or boom something
worse and if that happens they can look
back and trace a path a line of
connection between decisions that were
made and consequences they will then be
experiencing we can't compete with
that but they are not in competition
with
us they're in competition with the Holy
Spirit our challenge tonight is not to
get angry or un Christlike or worse yet
proud that we are not doing this stuff
our challenge is to allow God who loves
people to come in and tell us about our
real condition and to awaken within us
the conviction of a father who speaks
the truth in
love
Millennials or the activist
generation and social justice is the
christless pipeline for much of this
they believe that social justice or
socialism is the right side of history
and by the way they're ontologically
connected according to the marar College
of Bible in Saskatchewan Canada who has
committed a number of studies on
Millennials Millennials are particularly
vulnerable to and I will cite five
examples they are particularly
vulnerable to social
justice we can talk more about what that
really
is
later they're vulnerable to
environmentalism and I've observed this
in the on that I've worked with uh deep
green deep ecology dark green I'll just
give you an illustration that should
resonate with some of us last year
January the 4th
2014 the presiding Bishop this is the
the head of the Episcopalian Church it
was a woman Katherine Jeffs
shy said that she arrived at a view that
sin no longer exist effectively no
longer exists because
of God's mercy and forgiveness which is
eternal January 4th
2014 well it's still Sabbath so this
very
week this very
week Katherine Jeffords shy said
this about people who don't believe in
global warming and that's where I'm
heading with this statement Under The
Heading of of environmentalism How It's
coming in and how it's intertwined
wrapped around the axle like one of the
terrible twins Evolution and
environmentalism she said
this she said people who deny that
global warming is
happening are
sinful didn't you
just
yes changed her mind she changed her
mind number three this is from the
Millar College who was done a study on
Millennials there are Millen Millennials
are very vulnerable to global
citizenship which is a growing Movement
by the way of Which social justice is a
part and there's so many tentacles to
this thing it's very difficult to list
them all but it is a fascinating study
and I've devoted the last 11 years to
studying into the ATT tenance of
environmentalism and how it's it is
intertwined in this this paganism a
culting of the church by the way I'm not
against conver conservation please know
that there's a place for
that transformational events number four
Millennials are particularly vulnerable
to transformational events these are
festivals that are happening around the
world with more and more regularity
burning man would be one of them and
number five they are particularly
vulnerable to socialism and
Marxism
unquote now
Millennials for instance do not believe
that the constitution was and is a
bullwark against
totalitarianism and more importantly
they believe no longer they do not
believe that the Bible contains the
immutable will of God for all people
which begs the
question how can we reach
them many of them are
hurting Millennials need answers friends
to Life's hard
questions they need
answers and the
church must be available to help answer
those questions you call a lawyer you
expect an answer don't
you but not the
church we have the
answers you see Christianity is not
about a journey it's not about a
dialogue or a conversation the real
journey is the one that Jesus Took when
he spiraled down into a human cell and
stepped off the Throne of divinity Psalm
40 and the journey that he will take to
come back and judge the world in
righteousness we must engage Millennials
with something they may not believe in
truth but they'll know it when they hear
it the biblical Christ answers our deep
need for an efficacious
savior Redemption cannot be self-
salvation people know this deep down
talk to them talk to the young people
ask them can you save
yourself listen to their answers or ask
them is your life everything that you
hoped it would
be you catch them in a moment of honesty
tears may come as they look back on the
regrets they carry around there is a
solution there's a way to resolve those
regrets that's the good news tonight
recently I made a statement on social
media about the evils of drink as
Illustrated in the lives of naab and
Abu I was risky wasn't
it okay that's
wrong the resulting discussion was how
freedom in Christ makes drinking alcohol
okay for a Christian and I was reminded
of the scripture in Philippians 319
which says whose end is destruction
whose God is their belly and whose Glory
is in their shame who set their mind on
Earthly
things we must reach out to these kind
of people and care for them if we don't
who else
will another question that I like to ask
Millennials if you don't have the Bible
if you don't believe in it then how is
your God ever going to say no to
you saying yes all the time doesn't mean
a real relationship
it can lead to deep emptiness and deep
shame you see I have a goal I'd like to
see five couples in every
Church five couples in every Church it
could be
more and I would like these couples to
be the kind of couples who who love
people and who understand how the heart
works and they're there and they're
available they're available to
encourage maybe help people work through
and resolve issues but doesn't have to
be just five better yet that would be
that
everyone everyone would have that that
motive okay men my
brothers we're all familiar with that
classic Timeless statement the greatest
want of the world is the want of men and
that's true tonight you're needed
fathers
husbands young men you're
needed young men Paul wrote the special
message to you acknowledging your
strength it must be the right kind of
strength it must be the strength that
comes from
Heaven it has nothing to do with arm
wrestling but it has a lot to do with
wrestling with principalities and Powers
Men You're needed you're Meed take
charge in the right way serve your homes
in a way that will bless your wife that
will honor your wife love your children
put your arms around them once in a
while and say I'm glad you're part of
our
family I love you you're special to me
sisters you're needed you're needed and
God has gifted you in a number of unique
ways he has gifted you with the ability
to do a couple of things at the same
time something that I usually
lack and there's a great need for
you you bring a softening
influence when you submit your spirit to
your husband for a relationship
that in itself is
evangelism you want to be an evangelist
be a husband and a wife walking together
in Oneness that is
evangelism you'll be one in a thousand
there's an entire world out there
waiting to see this kind of
demonstration of God's love this
emblem of the
godhead the Everlasting gospel must
speak to shame and it
does many Millennials believe they are
bad people
many Millennials believe that they're
bad
people and the emerging Church through
social justice gives them a forum to
work off their shame never never works
never helps something else is needed the
best antidote to shame is to be fully
known and fully loved by another person
that's
powerful and that's what the god of
Heaven offers each one of
you the best antidote to shame my wife
and I have been privileged over the
years to work with a lot of young
people we've worked with them in
Scandinavia and number of places around
the
world Millennials are asking a lot of
questions there's a lot of uncertainty
and there's so much potential in each
one of them I'll give you an
illustration Millennials
are completely helpless to know how to
deal with
Isis just as an
illustration you see God does not call
us to put ex's on our enemy's eyes but
to pray that the Holy Spirit would open
their
eyes be available my friends be
available for these young people we need
their
energy they need our wisdom and
compassion you see as Adventists we are
the inheritors of that definition of God
through the Great
controversy many Millennials have picked
up this beautiful Advent Banner through
the efforts of gyc and others for
instance gyc is one of the best things
going in our church right
now a wonderful movement that I I kind
of half-hazard
grudgingly went to my first one in
2007 I was astounded by what I saw there
my son had two tickets he wanted to go
and his friend backed out he says well
Dad the lot fell on
you you want to go I said well sure I
went and I was deeply impressed by these
young people in Minneapolis they asked
me two questions I purposely would make
it a point to talk to them just say Hi
how are you I'm Jerry what's your name
how are you they would ask me two
things um what's your name what do you
do for a
Ministry I love that question
as you go out of here tonight ask
someone what do you what do what is your
ministry what is God how is God using
you to bless other
people beautiful wonderful question
anyhow that was
2007 gyc has done an admirable job of
resisting the intrusion of interfaith
mysticism in fact they have helped to
expose
it for instance where are they exposing
it one of the foremost strongholds for
this progress spirituality throughout
our country and in adventism is
Academia
uhoh Mr Wagner just mentioned the
elephant in the
room
yeah let me give you an example of how
far this thinking has penetrated into
our midst as Adventist Christians
especially in
Academia 34 days
ago there was a panel of Adventist
Scholars
who met to discuss the emerging Church
movement the meeting was moderated by
Chuck scriven who among other things
decried doctrinal
arrogance okay are you against
arrogance yeah the Bible's against it
and so am I are you against
Doctrine no I hope not and by binding
those two
together a false illustration was set up
but enough about that yes we should
decry
arrogance and humble ourselves each
morning before
God but I quote Dr Zay ye one of the
panel speakers who spoke regarding the
elements of truth I thought it was
fascinating he observed that
postmodernism holds that language
culture culture psychology and economics
contribute to our knowledge of the world
and therefore we possess no no method
for attaining absolute truth about the
world okay
quote for All Humans truth is
complicated God knows the truth but I'm
not God okay so far so good we humans
have no way of knowing the ultimate
truth there is only your truth and my
truth
stop stop what's wrong with that
statement well in that statement truth
becomes an individualized internal
construct you get to decide what truth
is that is a
subjective response to life you get to
decide what is
truth there is only your truth and my
truth and you'll hear that won't you how
many of you have heard the statement
well that may be true for
you I've heard that I've heard it almost
as many times as I've heard people say
I'm spiritual but not religious the
battlecry of monism
let's go on to make it sound sort of
faithy Dr Ye quotes from Paul in the New
Testament we see through a glass Darkly
that's that's biblical but what is he
saying what is he really
saying there is only your truth and my
truth I'd like to unpack that just for a
moment and if I bore you I apologize in
advance but first his statement is
rooted in radical doubt nurtured in 18th
century German
universities I've studied some of
this it is now almost everywhere
accepted in academic Community by the
way this modern doubt and it measures
all claims against the prior assumption
that nothing is to be accepted unless it
first clears the scrutiny of objective
rational examination that was kind of a
long boring sentence I
know but this everpresent product of the
humanist Enlightenment provides us with
exact
opposite of the biblical
model which is the biblical model rest
on initial Faith itself to be measured
against the standard of
Revelation Revelation because God spoke
it and his word secondly
secondly Dr Ye if I'm pronouncing that
correctly if I'm not I
apologize secondly he is articulating
the notion that absolute truth is
unknowable now this is a common
sentiment among
emergents for them every person is now
crafting for himself the true reality in
which he or she lives it does not come
from outside it is not something learned
from outside but the tools already
reside within the individual to work
upon what factual material may be
gathered or
acquired this means what does that mean
this means that there are no absolute
Universal truths that apply to everyone
for them reality is an individualized
creation let me put that in country
language it is the Book of Judges
coupled to social networking it is the
boom Festival blended with the Sabbath
it is based in feeling A celebratory
reflection of monism postmodernism you
see is slowly passing away
re-enchantment is the new paradigm a lot
of big words there what that means is
the times are changing and they're
changing fast and a little lady many
years ago wrote and said the final
movements would be rapid I submit to you
tonight dear friends we are in the midst
of that
prophecy
every every
person in this room has been somewhat
affected by these changes and since
reality for each person is an inter
construct different in every person
because no two people are exactly the
same the idea of One Sovereign Creator
who defines right and wrong becomes
untenable on this basis we must be
prepared to accept all other ideas and
behaviors as equally correct sound
familiar yeah
emergent
adventism another religion may be the
product of a culture and culture may not
be criticized
it must be accepted as valid for the
person holding it that may be true for
you remember the idea of trying to win a
person from One Faith to another then
becomes
immoral you see all religions under this
system are of equal value and legitimacy
equal Merit so any attempt to replace
one with another is oppression on these
grounds missionaries who went out from
America and
Europe couple of hundred years ago were
in fact
oppressors imposing a foreign religion
on innocent
victims Small Wonder Isn't
it that people who accept this new inner
Faith
spirituality now avoid all efforts of
evangelism unless they are evangelizing
your youth to their way of thinking of
course yes this is the world that we
have moved into concurrent with Paul's
warning in 2 Timothy 3:1 the dangerous
times were
coming are you sensitive dear
friends tonight to the power of
television in swaying public
opinion it's absolutely
disturbing and who is in charge of the
television cameras and what will be
shown and under what circumstances it
will be shown becomes actually the
controlling factor in modern thought in
the United States and there are hundred
examples we could look
at so each person is essentially his or
her own lone self and no activity has a
right to
intrude upon that person's private
rights by the way Nancy and I chose not
to have a television in our home which
was a very easy decision for me
being raised without one came out of the
anabaptist movement they don't have TV
they didn't have
radio all these were new things to me
when I became a young man so we tried a
TV for about three months then we threw
the bum out we we said no no we can't
afford
that we can't afford the influence
anyway and so today under this this new
shift the idea of melting into the
family of God becomes a reject now the
impact of such thinking increasingly
invades our church today and it's often
through
Academia and I did it again didn't
I sorry about that hard truth is truth
nonetheless
friends let me let me speak to you young
people here from the
heart not everyone has to go to college
okay not everyone has to go to college
especially if you know how to teach
yourself if you know how to apply
yourself to learning and I'm not
condemning college and higher learning
by the way but there are many kinds of
Education choose the kind that you allow
into your mind
wisely increasing numbers of people
think of themselves now in the church as
Adventist by Heritage or tradition
rather than by
conviction because of this they feel
free to pick and choose among the
doctrines of the
church assembling for themselves
cafeteria style a suitable
selection now the emphasis Falls rather
incidentally apart from objective truth
true because it was revealed by God the
stress today is falling upon a
relationship that relies no longer on
revealed truth as it does on inner
emotional
experience at its popular level
relationships suggests the coming
together of mere equal parties in a
format suggesting negotiated agreement
of some
kind and almost
missing from this formula is the sense
of all of what it means to come into the
presence of the almighty creator of the
universe
this is emerging adventism it is
lethargy on steroids and please know I
don't downgrade relationship each of us
need a relationship with
God and following that we will have a
relationship with other people people
that God brings into our lives that he
wants us to benefit from and benefit
them one quick word about positive
thinking I love positive
thinking but it has a downside did you
know
that recently a can't we all get a long
letter was circulated throughout the
North American
Division and while I appreciate the
effort it is an empty substitute for the
kind of
reconciliation repentance and
forgiveness that was presented in a
short video clip released by The Revival
and Reformation committee the title of
that video clip What Might Have Been
could be you can find it on ADV
vindicate and other
places that
experience in that video needs to happen
in our
church and I believe it will I was
fortunate to be a part of such a meeting
in the Church of my fathers many years
ago I will go to my grave remembering
that experience and I am confident that
those of us in this room will one day
hopefully soon have that same kind of
experience where we open our hearts up
to another person person and we say I'm
sorry in the way I've wronged you with
my words I'm sorry for hurting you and
misjudging you would you forgive me and
right there you knock on the heart of
that person you ask someone to forgive
you the balls in their Court they may
not be ready to go there maybe they
can't go there maybe their pride is
holding them back maybe their fear is
holding them back
nevertheless make that Overture make
that Overture to people when two people
do that you will have a relationship
that you can't tear apart
positive thinking affords you energy
motivation and initiative but if we're
always marry Poppin positive then we
often ignore reality don't
we the world doesn't function on wishful
thinking alone you see things don't
somehow magically get better or go away
just because we want them to or I want
them to especially if you are part of
the progressive
spirituality problem
if we don't start piling sandbags the
water is going to overflow The Levy
friends let's think honestly and then
let's act and let's be people of prayer
let's pray for
people the word of God had has as its
Essence transformative
truth a funny thing happens when people
lose contact with the word there have
been times in my
life where I've lost contact with the
word fortunately for only a brief period
perod of time but I tell you what it's
not a good place to be and God is always
there to call you
back and I'm grateful for my my daily
connection with the word of God but when
you lose that connection you seek
transformation
elsewhere and then you bring that
impoverishment and uncertainty into the
church the church is impoverished by a
desire to be conformed to the world
friends let me say this to you
there is hope there is
hope I quote Paul's letter to the Romans
be not conformed to this world that be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
that you may prove what is that good and
acceptable and perfect will of God you
see renewing our mind finds our voice it
gives us something to say it gives us a
word of encouragement and gives us truth
to bless the lives of others in summary
the emerging church has arisen From the
Ashes of
paganism it is a Christian form of
paganism if such a thing were
possible we know that it
is most of us know ad
321 and what
happened a Christian form of
paganism rocked our world and it is
trying to do it
again you see ref Reformation calls us
back to
something
reformation and we hear
the the heartfelt Cry of God in
Zechariah 1:3 who says return unto me
and I will return unto
you there's room for you there dear one
watching on the live
stream there's a reason it's called
Reformation just for can sometimes
become spiritual
formation takes you down a lot of long
roads well we're this new spirituality
to be given way in our church young
people would be totally divorced from
the Adventist message our church would
be separated from the gift and the life
saving Wonder of
repentance optimism is a good thing I
need it and you do
too but it can be become a negative
thing if it's not realistic Are you
standing by or standing up are you
standing
by or standing up coming soon to a
church near you what will it be friends
will it be true repentance and
Reformation or a false one made in the
image of inner Faith
mysticism
friends we don't need a race to the
left we don't even need a race to the
middle we need a race towards
righteousness you might be thinking I
wish someone would sum all this up in a
few
words they
have I'll quote it to you as
spiritualism more closely imitates the
nominal Christianity of the day it has
greater power to deceive and in snare
Satan himself is converted after the
modern order of things he will appear in
character as an angel of Light through
the agency of spiritualism Miracles will
be wrought the sick will be healed and
many undeniable wonders will be
performed and as the spirits will
profess faith in the Bible and manifest
respect for the institutions of the
church their work will be
accepted as divine power great
controversy
588 next page the line of distinction
between professed Christians and the
ungodly is now hardly
distinguishable that's sad when that
happens we are called To Be A peculiar
people in the right way the kind of
people that others want to be around the
kind of people who on their deathbed can
say when I was around
you I wanted to know
God that's what I want to hear someone
say about you someday church members
love what the world loves and our ready
to join with them and Satan determines
to unite them in one body and thus
strengthen his cause by sweeping all
into the ranks of spiritualism
papus who boast of Miracles as a certain
sign of the true church will be readily
deceived by this Wonder working power
and not just them my words but
Protestants having Cast Away the shield
of truth will also be deluded papist
Protestants and worldlings will alike
accept the for of godliness without the
power and they will see in this Union a
grand movement for the conversion of the
world and the ushering in of the long
expected
Millennium that's a utopian Vision which
all too often ends in a dystopian
nightmare it is social justice on
steroids I
close with a
poem that I wrote two weeks ago I hated
poetry when I was in high school
then I became a Believer God softened my
heart as we passed through the
exhibitions of every age and race we
looked for Hope and Truth while it
stared Us in the
face we dwelt in a guilty City where
rule was the law of sin the heavens
revealing the glory of God were hidden
from
Babylon we set sail to the Advent Shore
bowed down by airs chain we hit the
beach we called to God and waited for
the
rain the Lord reached out his hand to us
the father of
compassion through him we found in the
holy word a landmark of
creation we had given our hearts away
they were purchased back with blood a
world condemned had need to know as
controversy brood it was large enough
this task at hand the Everlasting news
and larger still to shun the lust which
threatened to
confuse we wandered by the doorway of
temptation's angry face and every time
we passed that way we always heard our
name but the Advent movement continued
though some drifted out of touch they
questioned our Lord's return they said
we didn't know
much they turned their face toward the
East they ushered in the Mystic they
loathed the rest for many things they
claimed we were
patristic they ran to the emergence and
de bait concealed a hook for thinking
outside the box readed thinking outside
the
book on the feminist
Sandstone they promised
egalitarianism they sliced and diced the
word and gutted
adventism so onward in our journey we've
come to understand the progress safe
oneway ticket leads back to
Babylon it's time to press together and
hold our Bibles close say no to monus
thinking and mystical
intercourse as the holy building
trembles and appears as if to
fall God brings the remnant forward
Beyond The Wailing
Wall Lo now the Sun is setting it rests
on the wheel and plow as Christ dispels
the darkness
seara sacred
cow
amen for